. So as we already we started the show today
talking about the explosion of vaccination,
eight point eight million vaccinations happening
over this weekend, Friday, Saturday, Sunday.
We are now right around two and a half million
vaccinations per day, probably going higher.
This is not by chance.
This was exactly what Joe Biden ran on doing
from before day one.
He put in place infrastructure and a team
to increase vaccinations as quickly as possible.
And it's happening now.
A lot of people are insisting Trump, Trump,
Trump credit for the vaccines.
We will talk in the next segment about why
there's really very little Trump gets credit
for on the vaccines.
He gets credit for not obviously standing
in the way, although downplaying the seriousness
of the virus is making it so that half of
Trump voters don't want the vaccine.
So we'll talk about Trump's role a little
bit later.
But let's talk about Joe Biden.
On Thursday night, Joe Biden told The nation
during his first primetime White House address
as president, which got higher ratings than
Trump's first one.
And that seems to be highly triggering to
many.
Joe Biden said he believes we have and will
have enough supply for every state to make
all adults, meaning 18 plus eligible for vaccine
appointments as of May 1st.
And many right wingers are absolutely furious.
Let's take it step by step.
Here is what Joe Biden said late last week.
First tonight, I'm announcing that I will
direct all states, tribes and territories
to make all adults people 18 and over eligible
to be vaccinated no later than May one.
Let me say that again.
All adult Americans will be eligible to get
a vaccine no later than May one.
This is a major accomplishment.
Say what you want about Biden on minimum wage,
the stimulus taking too long, not managing
the border situation well enough.
I'm with you.
I've been on all of those stories.
But the way Trump rolled out vaccination,
we were thinking about maybe 18 plus by September,
maybe mid-August, May 1st.
Eligibility for all adults is powerful and
it is huge.
Joe Biden also saying which triggered the
right very much something optimistic, that
the way things are going, we are likely to
be able to have July 4th gatherings, not necessarily
rangers with five hundred people, but gatherings.
Take a look at that.
And finally, fifth, and maybe most importantly,
I promise I will do everything in my power.
I will not relent until we beat this virus,
but I need you.
The American people, I need you, I need every
American to do their part.
That's not hyperbole, I need you I need you
to get vaccinated when it's your turn and
when you can find an opportunity.
And to help your family, your friends, your
neighbors get vaccinated as well, because
here's the point.
If we do all this, if we do our part, we do
this together.
By July the 4th, there's a good chance you,
your families and friends will be able to
get together in your backyard or in your neighborhood
and have a cookout and a barbecue and celebrate
Independence Day.
That doesn't mean large events with lots of
people together, but it does mean small groups
will be able to get together, without a doubt.
Joe Biden's best speech and public events
so far and the right is simply furious.
Here is right wing bomb thrower Mark Levin,
considered an intellectual to the modern reactionary
right wing movement, calling this speech the
most disgusting speech ever given by a politician.
This speech that Joe Biden gave is the most
disgusting propagandistic speech that a demagog
even a politician has ever given.
It is pathetic, just completely irate about
it.
Here is Laura Ingraham weighing in with Sean
Hannity, calling the speech a funeral for
America.
What you think of this speech?
Well, I think it was supposed to be inspiring.
It seemed a tad like a funeral for America,
however.
So that's my quick take.
I don't even know if she saw the speech from
what she's saying, a funeral for America after
Trump was vaccinating only about eight hundred
and fifty thousand a day.
We did nearly nine million in a weekend.
We're opening vaccination to all adults by
May 1st.
Biden is saying we're going to have 4th of
July gatherings.
It's the opposite of a funeral.
They don't seem to like the good news.
And then here is Laura Ingraham on her own
excuse me, on her own show, saying there is
a double standard because the left likes Joe
Biden saying July 4th looks good, but they
didn't like Donald Trump saying Easter of
2020 looks good last year.
And she says there's a hypocrisy because of
this.
Take a look.
Well, what were the journalists saying?
Their reaction to the Pseudo-Science?
I think it was very moving.
I thought it was really important that when
he talked about that July 4th goal, he is
the guy we need right now.
July 4th, you know, he put that on the calendar
as well.
So barbecue, right?
People are going to be looking at their calendars
now with some hope.
If we all do our part by the Fourth of July,
we might be able to celebrate Independence
Day together, which would be incredible.
I don't even know who that last person was
with the mask.
Who was that?
Oh, Chris Hayes.
OK, now how is that based in any science?
Now, I seem to remember a different reaction
from the press corps who were crucifying Trump
for pegging reopening to a holiday last spring.
President Trump pushing the country to get
up and running by Easter, but top medical
experts are warning it is much, much too soon.
We're going to have everything lifted by Easter.
Now, the president saying I want the whole
world to be opened up by Easter and think
about what Bill Gates just said.
You do that too early and you're going to
be ignoring all the bodies in the corner.
Gosh, I hadn't seen that until just then.
Now, of course, the truth is the press was
acting like the Commerce Department for the
DNC last spring.
Laura, the difference between Trump saying
will be open by Easter 20-20.
And Biden saying small Fourth of July gatherings
is that it was ridiculous to talk about Easter
of 20 20.
There was never any chance of that happening.
No medical experts thought that was possible.
It was a joke.
It was laughable.
Trump was, again, the humiliation globally
of the United States when we had just started
taking any measures in mid-March.
And Trump was saying in April, we're going
to be wide open.
Every single one of those comments about Easter
of 2020 was correct.
It was nutty to think of opening an Easter
of 2020.
And then Laura Ingram.
And I think this is really what makes them
mad.
Laura Ingram had a panel on which someone
named Mollie Hemingway said It's un-American
for Joe Biden to say he might allow gatherings
on July 4th, which is, of course, not what
he said.
Take a look again.
And then to pick Independence Day as the day
where he says he might allow people to gather
is just so un-American.
And and just, you know, Joe Biden doesn't
get to tell me when I can have a barbecue
in my backyard and certainly not to tie that
to Independence Day.
And, of course, people have been barbecuing
this entire time.
It's not a question of permission.
It's for those who pay attention to the CDC
and what public health experts say the way
things are pointing are we could safely do
this.
It's not about permission.
It's about working together.
And it continued all night and even into the
next day.
From that same night, Sean Hannity ran a headline
called Biden Should Thank Trump for Vaccine.
And I tweeted about this asking, can anyone
explain to me what Trump actually did on vaccination?
Any government would generally fund research.
It's not special.
Are we supposed to thank him, Trump for not
going out of his way to prevent vaccine development?
Trump now wants credit for a vaccine.
He said we didn't actually need to end the
pandemic to end a pandemic that he said wasn't
serious anyway.
And a vaccine which he received in private
in January and kept a secret until we learned
last week that he had been vaccinated, which
also doesn't encourage people to go out and
get vaccinated.
They are simply furious that this is going
well per capita on vaccination rates.
It's Israel, the United Arab Emirates, the
UK and Chile, and then the United States.
We are in the top five vaccinators in the
world per capita.
The next countries down have done only like
a sixth of the vaccinations per capita that
we have and the right can't take it part of.
By the way, we're going to talk later about
Anthony Forces' comments about why aren't
Republicans wanting to get vaccinated.
Part of it is they were told this wasn't serious
for a year.
Part of it is they believe that them getting
vaccinated helps Joe Biden be able to say,
look at all the vaccinations.
So I expect them to keep this going probably
straight into the 2022 election and we'll
be covering it through.
And until then, next Friday, the 26th, we
are running a massive one day membership promo.
Why?
Well, the reason why isn't the best.
It's that February was our worst month in
terms of memberships in over a year.
A lot of people hit with financial trouble.
February, only twenty eight days less time
for people to sign up.
Disastrous month for us.
So next Friday, the 26th, we're doing a membership
blowout.
It'll be a sort of vaccination related coupon
code.
If you want to be notified, just get on my
mailing list at David Pakman Dotcom and you'll
get an email bright and early next Friday
morning.